yeah and I also feel that things that I
repetitively think about or say I'm able
to manifest like you know this house for
example I manifested this because I
obsessively used to take my uncle's Audi
and I used to take a girl to Young and
Eglinton Silver City to the movies and
then to pickle barrel for for dinner and
then I used to go tell her like yo you
want to go see where I'm gonna live one
day because this is where I'm gonna live
one day and I my uncle had an outing I
used to drive them these same three
streets right here that used to be my
route right there I used to come down
down Parkway and where we're at
then back back to Post Road and then
back Bridle Path and I used to and
Prince used to live around here oh wow
wow so I used to I used to pretend like
I knew which one princess house was
every night I picked a different house
while you're on the journey you have to
disconnect from the end goal you know
because if you're just focused on some
end goal then you're you might get there
but it'll be hard to progress past that
because you're so focused on that one
destination that it's like you know you
you maybe forget everything in between
and maybe you could have done more in
between just be he always told me like
just be here right now live right now
and do the best you can right now don't
worry about what that end goal is it's
great to have goals it's great to have
dreams but it's just like you get too
attached to it and sometimes it can be a
self-destructive thing so I mean I just
kind of try and progress as much as I
can why do you care so much about
success have you figured that up I'm
just addicted to it why
um
I think that I've
sacrificed so much for it already and
dedicated so much of my time that I have
to push it as far as I possibly can
because I've
given up a lot of years as far as
maybe like nurturing like personal
relationships go and you know trying to
build things like a family or a
relationship or I don't I don't like I
don't do any of that I just kind of work
at this point in my life I'm okay with
that you know as you receive things in
life money blessings whatever your
appetite begins to grow right so it's
like if I give you a million dollars
tomorrow you're going to learn what it's
like to have a million dollars and then
you're gonna start being around people
that have 10 million dollars or 100
million dollars you're going to learn
that there's other things that you can't
get with a million dollars so your
appetite grows and I think
the initial visions that I had for
myself just kind of manifest the feeling
I get when I'm out in the world is one
of one of respect I think that my career
has a lot of integrity and I think I'm
very excited about that because I think
I could have let that drop a bunch of
times and I also think one of my biggest
accomplishments is the fact that I
didn't let this
massive massive change in my life
destroy me you know I still don't I'm I
still don't do drugs you know I drink
but
even if I drink every day I don't drink
to black out I don't drink to escape my
sadness I don't drink to the point that
affects my family or my career
I think I'm just happy that I'm still
intact you know that's my biggest
accomplishment I made a lot of money you
know I made a lot of
did a lot of things been a lot of places
had a lot of opportunities to this up
and didn't
and you know
I could be at dinner with my mom and
still hear her say like you know I'm
proud you're still you you're in there
you know I'm looking at you you're there
it's you it's not like a shell of who
you used to pee or something like that
you know
I love my space
I love my work
and I love my routine and for me to
break that for somebody
it would just have to be like a really
special person that fits into that
puzzle and that is supportive of the
things I'm doing had to be somebody that
has taste in music it'd have to be
somebody that that I get along with so
much to the point that when we're
separate I'm feeling like I can't
function properly without their presence
I'm really self-conscious about my music
and um even if I do a good job I always
wonder you know how I could have done it
better
I rarely celebrate anything and um just
for anyone watching this that's
wondering how this happened you know
that's really the answer it's um
it's being so unsure how you're getting
it done that you just you just kind of
keep going in the hopes of figuring out
the formula
um just feeling so lucky and blessed
that the fear of losing it keeps you up
at night
I didn't really write a grandiose speech
about how to make it work or what it
took because you know to be really
honest with you I don't I don't quite
understand it myself I know that I've
spent an incalculable amount of hours
trying to analyze all the things I did
wrong
when I made a choice
to start singing
it was because of something that my
father had told me which was you know
there's no rapper out there that sings
and raps and does it well does both
things well and he's like in order to be
successful you're gonna need something
other than just what everyone else
Twitter isn't real by the way it's not
like any like there's no gauge on like
real life on Twitter that like that
that's a terrible medium to like exist
in and you can enjoy it you can even
indulge in it but like just don't live
your life by that weird code on that
internet program
so if there's something for you to
express it has to be your own thing like
I don't know what you like to do maybe
you like to like do yo-yos and yo-yo is
your self-expression weird example but
hey maybe it's like painting maybe it's
uh making clothing like I'm not sure
what it is as far as expressing your
feelings
if you happen to be one of those people
that's eloquent enough and you you know
you enjoy words then I always encourage
you to do it any way you see fit whether
it's poetry music or whether it's just
direct communication with people but
like get off the internet like tell
somebody like come meet me for a drink
let's have dinner let's go for a walk
you know like real life
I don't know anybody what you have to
understand is like there's a way to
exist in this world that's like it we've
never had it before but like I strongly
believe in the fact that if you have a
good product
for the first time ever
there's a way to like get the world
to hear your product
and if it's good
you will see the results from it you
understand I'm saying like artists will
drop a mixtape and if that mixtape picks
up you know whether it's like House of
balloons or party next door like I
remember seeing when House of balloons
dropped I remember people being like yo
I'm in the Netherlands right now
listening to House of balloons it's like
you know we have such a platform to
access the entire world and my biggest
thing to you your question was how do
you like I guess catch the attention
it's just about finding your own moment
you know and and having the music be
great as cliche as that sounds but it's
just like man you know there's not a lot
of great music to choose from so when
somebody is great the world will let you
know trust me it doesn't take me it
doesn't take this guy the world will let
you know all you have to do is put it
out there and there are people who scour
the internet every day looking for the
next big thing and I promise you if that
product that you have is potent enough
you will be the next big thing and I
feel like that's it you know
what does money mean to you well I think
less than the dollar value it's just
more about
um the idea of growth and business
business mindset to you know 25 million
um at the time seemed crazy to me but
when you start becoming a headlining
touring act and you know Brands want to
get involved with you and you can go do
private events and whatnot it's you know
you're capable of making it and now I
want to you know for sure obviously keep
touring keep making music but now I see
that there's other ways
um as far as like you know this Global
Ambassador thing as far as maybe
starting I want to invent some I want to
start a company I want to do something
that has maybe nothing to do with music
why do you care so much about success
have you figured that up
well
I don't want to be number two I think
that would be a weird thing to sit here
and say or I don't care what you know I
I want to make this the city proud you
know that that's that's a main reason
for me and number one it takes a while
to even become that I I don't I don't I
don't even know what number it's like
number I hate numbers by the way you
know
um
I I like to say I just want to win you
know